ground control has lost communication
with the craft they fear something
catastrophic may have occurred I've
dreamt of this moment two of us teaming
up I pray we can only hope wherever he
is she's watching that she's seeing this
hey youtubers its charlie
we finally have Superman on Supergirl so
let's break it down there's also some
really cool stuff The CW is doing in
terms of streaming it shows online so
I'll explain that too I like the way
they use dialogue in this oh my god I
dreamt of this for so long
Superman we're gonna team up and it's
gonna be so awesome so you hear people
from metropolis caster from metropolis
in the newscaster from National City
where Supergirl lives both saying I hope
she's hearing this I hope he's hearing
this so it sounds like this giant
spacecraft is crashing into the
atmosphere somewhere either between
their cities or just so big and
catastrophic that everyone would just
assume that Superman would take care of
it but now you have Supergirl she's only
been on the scene for about a year so
while the National City people are
waiting for Supergirl to help out there
weren't really any markings on the
helmets or the spacecraft to let you
know this might be from Cadmus labs
think I mean it could be NASA or it
could be Luthor Corp because there are a
couple different people that we have to
meet like new characters Lena Luthor's
gonna make her first appearance metallo
is gonna make his first appearance he'll
definitely come from Cadmus labs but we
don't really know why it is the
Supergirl and Superman have to go meet
with Lena Luthor only that the
spacecraft crashing seems like the first
moment of their crossover like the first
moment they encounter each other like
they both fly up to save it and then
they look at each other and then you get
that dialogue oh my god I've always
dreamt of us teaming up together and
then after all that business you get him
coming to National City to visit as
Clark Kent and a reporter we do see cat
grant but she's not going to be in every
single episode this season so we'll
probably meet the person that she's
installing as her replacement like the
day-to-day manager the vibe I'm getting
from him I think you guys will like the
dynamic between him and Cara and the
other characters just in general I think
that was just some weirdness with the
way they wrote cat grant like they never
quite figured out how to make her seem
like a really badass older female
without making her sound like a really
catty high school kid making fun of
other people all the time but it seems
really cool I mean there's not a whole
lot of other footage other than just
teasing the fact that it's gonna be this
huge team up with Superman he's not
gonna be in every single episode they
didn't say exactly how many episodes
he's gonna be in but I'm guessing he'll
at least like three or four more times
you know at least in like a more
physical way some crossovers will
probably be bigger than others like
you'll actually see Clark Kent show up
to work on a case or you'll see some big
villain the Supergirl can only defeat
with Superman's help like whenever he
shows up it will be a big if it'll be
like something really cool happening I
almost forgot to Tekin Locke men from
the 100 and you know many other Joss
Whedon Productions is going to be
playing roulette during season two she
even posted this video just thanking
everybody for making so much noise
people went crazy online when they found
out but she's gonna be really bad as
it's gonna be a lot of fun I just wanted
to thank everybody for all the
excitement about me appearing on
Supergirl
as roulette the cast and crew working so
hard and they're such incredible people
I'm really excited to be on the show and
I can't wait for you to see it so
episode one if you guys didn't know is
October 10th at 8 p.m. on the CW the
other really cool thing for those of you
that watch all the episodes online most
of the stuff that I watch is online too
The CW is making changes to the way it
streams its shows online so if you're
looking for one of the DC CW shows you
can typically watch it for free online
on one of the CW platforms so these are
all the places that it's going to be
streaming those episodes typically they
make them available the morning after
they air on TV so like the flash for
instance airs Tuesday nights you would
be able to watch it for free on all
these platforms online by Wednesday
morning and for those of you that have
been asking about Netflix because
they've been waiting for forever to put
the previous seasons on Netflix they
change their deal with Netflix and now
what's gonna happen is is after the
season is over like after episode twenty
two twenty three airs in the spring next
year they're gonna put the entire season
online so you won't have to wait to the
end of the summer before watching all
these episodes on Netflix so it's really
cool and it's just them trying to catch
up with the idea that everybody
typically watches TV online like not a
lot of young people own TVs or even
watch TV most of the time you're looking
for a place to watch this on your
computer legally so now it's just going
to be easier to do that so that's just
CW but most of the other networks also
do the same thing so like Gotham on Fox
episode ones dropping tonight I mean I'm
totally gonna do a video for it but they
also put episodes online the morning
after 2:00 so if you don't watch it on
TV tonight you can watch it online
tomorrow morning but because we finally
saw the Superman
Supergirl trailer I would not be
surprised if they drop a new flash
trailer tomorrow because that's
premiering in two weeks and I'll talk a
little bit more about that the next time
I post a flash video because just like
Supergirl there's a bunch of new
characters a bunch of big changes we
have flashpoint we have dr. alchemy we
have sabot our we have the rival so
there's a bunch of new villains bunch of
new heroes to explain so it's gonna be
really awesome there is a new round of
the flash giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video it's just a gift
card for the value of the season to
blu-ray so what's gonna happen tonight
is I'll post my Gotham episode 1 video
after the episode airs there's some
really cool Game of Thrones
spin-off news that I was going to do but
be you know because Gotham is dropping
tonight I'll do that
then I'll do Game of Thrones in probably
a flash trailer tomorrow so a lot of
really awesome stuff happening pretty
much everything is coming back like all
the TV shows will be back in the next
two to three weeks so just a reminder
YouTube made some changes to make it a
little bit easier for you guys to watch
all this stuff on your mobile phones on
your tablets so if you're watching on
mobile right now you can actually click
on the links that I put at the end of
videos so if you guys do have any
problems getting any of this stuff just
let me know in the comments because
there's always all kinds of YouTube bugs
whenever they roll new features out but
get hype new Gotham coming tonight well
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for my last big flash trailer
I posted and you can click here for the
first couple of minutes from agents of
shield episode 1 which is tomorrow thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight